Jonathan your first film was Hunger yeah
okay well my first feature length film
feature i did i did a short just to kind
of get the feel of what the what it's
like to make a movie kind of block it
and then to edit it that was just really
a sketch hunger was the first movie
animated okay where were you in your
life at this time what year was this
it's actually about three years ago I
had been writing screenplays for almost
six years at the time but based on a
blog post at a friend of my man he's
like you got to kind of make your own
dreams come true no one's gonna open a
door for you he's got to do it and so
based on that I did it okay yeah and
what were the steps that you took what I
mean like I'm sure you thought it was
going to be easy or did you think it was
going to be hard or I knew that there
would be a lot of logistical problems
one of the things I really don't like
that I had to deal with a lot because my
first film had I use mostly college
students so working around their
schedules so scheduling wasn't fun but
keeping track of the amount of footage
that you get for a feature-length film
different cuts different takes different
locations different angles it's just a
lot of stuff to keep track of but it's
not it wasn't particularly difficult
there's just a lot of work and if you
kind of are methodical about it and you
say this is seen to take to you know
angle for and just label it and then
store it that way then it's really quite
manageable okay well then hindsight
three years later whatever what what
have you learned that you would never do
again and what are things that you would
most certainly do again what if you
could take a new filmmaker under your
wings what would you tell them well the
first thing I tell them is it's it's
totally doable I think there's this big
motif or thinking in Hollywood that that
you need a certain amount of money to do
something or that you need someone's
permission or anything like that and and
I was I remember sitting in this room
with his guy he was like i need at least
ninety thousand dollars to make a horror
movie and I said dude I shot my first
film for less than two thousand dollars
and I did it and it's a feature-length
film I and I said I can do the same
thing with your horror movie in this
apartment and he had gone to film school
and it's just like they indoctrinate the
idea that it needs to be done a certain
way but thanks to tools like even what
we're recording with this the 5d it's
just shattered what's possible we can do
anything do you think thats what stops a
lot of people they get that film degree
and they think it has to be perfect i
know there was someone that we knew that
was like oh our first film's would be
half a million i mean it's like the
first film do you think that that stops
a lot of people because if they can't
make it totally excellent Waimea Bay at
all well there's a couple things I think
that go on one is the budget people are
afraid that they need a certain amount
of money because everyone said that
that's the case and that with the budget
comes different things like with with a
bigger budget to get different actors
and you need certain like Hollywood says
you need a certain caliber of actor to
sell the movie or you need some kind of
name to do that and you know I both know
filmmakers who have done movies that
have been successful without names at
all or very small names that are
affordable but that and then also
there's there's as an artist it's kind
of difficult to there's this it's like
when I was writing screenplays and
before that I was writing novels it's
it's hard to get to the point where
you're willing to put
stuff out there because that's kind of
like your soul and you're burying it for
people and in and in art everybody
thinks that there's this de facto
standard by which things are judged so
they're going to compare your work to it
and it's like am I good enough do people
like me can I deal with that kind of
rejection so I think it's both those
things and also a drive it is a lot of
work it's not hard work it's not
impossible work I don't think it takes a
specific kind of person to do it just
you have to be willing to not stop
because i think i was getting like six
hours sleep five hours sleep a night for
three or four months you just have to be
willing to do that and is that a
challenge that you saw come up maybe did
you not think that that was a part of
this and then you realize well there's a
lot of tedious not so glamorous work
involved am I really ready to do all
this was that a challenge to spine that
information out no I mean I I had I had
done some PA work so I knew there was a
lot of work involved and a lot of the PA
jobs that had worked were 12 14 hour
days so I knew that each day that I
worked that's probably what my schedule
was going to be plus the
behind-the-scenes stuff so it wasn't the
work and it was it was it wasn't even
for me it wasn't that because it was
like like I said if I wanted my dream to
happen there was no one that was going
to make it happen I had to get up and do
it okay and so that's what drove me and
that's what gave me the energy and of
course this support of my wife which was
amazing she was always there egging me
on so you got to have you got to have
emotional support to but it was it was
that that real reality that the dreams
not going to happen unless I do it
because there's so many people who are
as talented or more talented than myself
who are willing to work for it and so
they don't need to come and find someone
who isn't those wait for the droves to
come to them we always hear that the
movie that you set out to make never is
that in
kind of dictates to you what it wants to
be did you find that out with your first
film did it evolve into something that
you hadn't planned I think I think that
they're kind of um there's there's
there's like three or four stages of
writing something there's that where you
have the idea it's kind of one writing
and then when it's on script it kind of
becomes something else when you're
filming it it becomes another thing when
you're editing it it becomes yet another
thing and then when people see it they
take their interpretation for it so is
it the film I planned yes and no I mean
it was the script for sure it feels the
way I wanted it to feel but what people
take from it I mean I can't it can only
do my part I can't dictate what people
think about things did you go to the
festival route with it or did you say
you know what this is sort of my this is
my thesis I'll be allah's really my big
issue is promotion and selling I have no
idea what to do with something once i
have it i can get it i can create it i
can make it but once i have it I'm like
okay now I've got this thing what do I
do it I did submit it to a festival so
that mostly because I the actors kind of
as an agreement so that they could get
IMDb credit a lot of festivals will
automatically sign you up for IMDb so it
was a small fee to do that that's why I
did it I didn't I mean yes we kind of
hope that that the moguls of Hollywood
will see my film
it gave me eight million dollars to make
my next movie but
a lot of competition out there well I'm
curious about the marketing angle
because I know that's that's a part that
trips us all up unless you're sort of
wired that way and you've gone to school
for that what is it about the whole
marketing process do not like that
self-promotion does that turn you off
and you see it in other people it's it's
not the self-promotion as much I mean I
appreciate the need for it like John
Paul rice is brilliant if I can ever do
something with him I will do it
immediately because he is is really good
at what he does he's a producer you know
you know yeah mother's red dress yes
mother's red dress when one of our
fantasy girl and then he's working on
another film and way that guy promotes
is amazing oh he's brilliant at it he's
gifted gifted speakers yeah and Anna
darn nice guy yeah um but he I can't do
what he can do I don't end when I watch
and do it I don't see it as is like
shameless either I mean he does it is
there's a dignity about it so I don't
think it's necessarily has to be that
way right but I it's just I mean I it's
it's I guess it's like any other aspect
of the film I did go to film school I
taught myself how to do all the things
that i do and i guess i'll just have to
teach myself how to promote it too so
what are some of the things that you've
done since then to kind of break out of
that anti marketing mode have you done
anything have you had to push yourself
more it wasn't that I was anti marketing
necessarily I'm just no good at it okay
some people are naturally good at it
like I wasn't the cool guy in school
like you know one of my brother my
brothers were that way I wasn't I wasn't
the guy you'd vote for president I had
plenty of friends yeah I wasn't an
outcast necessarily but I just that's
just not my personality and so marketing
and selling things and talking to people
about things is not the way I naturally
do things I I guess deep inside of me I
still hope that simply by making
something that is really good that that
will naturally rise
top like like the Bears video right
right but you can see to that he was
able to once he saw that people wanted
him around he saw oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you definitely got to walk through doors
when they opened right i mean what what
doors do not at the same time i mean i
am trying to network in hollywood and
meet people and find out like like I
said I I have to learn this right so
what does that entail because it would
going to events for mixers or just
trying to to just connect with others
yeah I think it's coming at it from a
lot of different angles like my brother
owns an ad agency and they do a lot of
social media so I talked to them about
what are the most effective methods of
the advertising vs dollar to you know
return on investment joke and Biagio
also talked about it a lot and they're a
great source and they talk about like
some of the best hundred dollars they
spent was their facebook ads Wow so just
learning where to do it when to do it
how to do it it's thinking of it as a
math equation as opposed to this art
project